hey leute herzen kommen zu meiner
heutigen video ich sitz hier zusammen
mit einem segway was geben
jetzt hat ja nicht mehr dinge ein
bisschen luca einmal übel ja ich bin
nicht nur körperlich paket leute ich
sitze zusammen mit luca denn wir beide
sind teil der reihe im special ist
kampagne zum neuen call of duty
letztens hat nämlich wie ist ja noch mal
mister activision hat bei ihr geklingelt
hat bürger gefragt ob er nicht lust hat
mit mir bei der kampagne zu machen weil
lustigen rausnahm istrien bei lazio ist
gefragt wenn ich vollkommen partien zu
spielen und das werden wir tun nicht
irgendwas sondern den neuen black out
modus ist krank wird richtig erhält so
ein battle royale modernen mann springt
von oben runter und muss sich sachen
sammeln und läuft am anfang mit händen
raum aber wir werden dich gemacht und
nutzt hätten wir uns nicht was
besonderes überlegt ihr seht hier die
magische schüssel der aufgaben die heißt
wirklich so die herzkatheter sowie
supermarkt ich dazu erwartet wie sony
heute herrscht und zwar befinden sich
hier kleine aufgaben drehna h
das sagt ja nein darin befinden sich
aufgaben und eine aufgabe muss immer
dann erfüllt werden wenn zum beispiel
ich drei kills mache muss luca dreimal
ziehen und drei aufgaben erfüllen und
nicht drei kids mache ich weiß es nicht
so genau ist wenn man gar keinen kilmer
gut dass du sagst muss man es selbst
eine aufgabe ziehen
und ich würde sagen du kannst du fängst
einfach mal an ich bin sehr gut du musst
natürlich jetzt einen spezialisten sehen
charakter worte du bist natürlich sport
bzw
wir sind im topf und team crash lukas
spezialist ist ob die freude die kameras
omega publiziert wir wissen dass wir
darum gucken ist okay das gesetz schon
wir fliegen runter auf die web
beziehungsweise lukas der vorbereitungs
bereit
das ding ist ja wir stehen ja nicht
einfach so sondern wir müssen trainieren
es wird derweil ein call of duty turnier
geben haben übrigens nicht gegen
irgendwelche anderen spieler sondern
tatsächlich auch gegen andere influenza
die auch ihre eigenen teams aufbauen die
unter anderen wäre es beispielsweise
beim was jetzt kommen wir ja kräftiges
gustav jahre den menge andere leute auf
jeden fall muss wirklich sagen wie matt
ist riesig also ich habe auch irgendwie
ein bisschen schiss davor dass wir gegen
die ganzen anderen spielen ich habe
richtig angesagt aber deshalb trainieren
wir jetzt ok und da geht's auf die karte
hier sind schon die aufgaben die sich
eventuell erwarten komme ich fliege
direkt in diesem fall ähnelt ihr
natürlich alter alter stelle am besten
jetzt im haus sein wobei die so wichtige
tipps
nein ich hab jetzt schon mehr schläge
gelandet als nur ein straßenschild wie
ich jetzt und dann hab ich wirklich
vermisst ich würde sagen ich spiele die
runde ist einfach zu ende
beschimpft hatte ich dachte da wären
abgaben
draußen kann bekommen hat er die
abschluss kamera angucken führen kannst
du sagen dies jetzt noch weiter
großartig sehr gut ich habe eine aufgabe
gezogen
wir wissen dass ich sehr viel sagt
jürgens mitte wird ekelhaft babyklappe
aktiv frauen 1
die schüssel hatte schüttler direkt ein
löffel senf essen ja okay ich mal kurz
denn von den löffel ok freunde seine
letzte willst du mir auf getrockneter
wahrheit es sogar jeder heute der es ist
der scharfe mitgliedschaft kann die
gleiche raus bin ich schwöre da war
etwas hartes die torhüter sind solche
crashes ausgewählt der controller ist in
meinen händen ich klick auf starten und
jetzt dafür dass es keinen einzigen
kircher türkisch ist etwas was ich soll
richtig viele aufgaben für dich zu haben
hatte sie gesagt das ding ist
ich bin halt dafür bekannt ist richtig
viel kills machen kannst der fis bekannt
die vorbereitungs bereichen erledigt
jetzt einfach hier schon alle teilte er
über gleichermassen kampfkraft unter
aussagen
erst krank das ist immer so ein gerät zu
pflücken
bislang aber es gibt wie ich höre ist
kann bestimmen was ich können das nur so
viel es ist auf jeden fall schon mal in
dieser saison genau in der zone 2 direkt
am rand der zone aber ich bin in der
zone j wie sie mich verraten oder
versteckt sich dahinter das gut
das hat die hitze machte wir können
weiter thema küssen würde ich würde ich
nicht machen
die kurz vor der geschüttelt schüssel
das schießen aber ist kein tor schießen
kommt der sehr gute oder der rasiert ist
ehrlichkeit würde ich heute gesehen dass
der tumor
ja dort ist bedarf vielleicht noch ein
bisschen übung bis es losgeht mit dem
von ihr weil wir werden ein film nicht
hinkommt demonstrativ wenig zeit wir
brauchen wir heute okay werden streng
diesmal ganz streng
alle video to play wertung spiegel steht
vor der tür zu schlüssel hat gesagt
scheiße gutes powerplay
ja und wie ihr wisst ich wollte ich weiß
ja bedenken da wirklich der richtige
begriff ist ja bereits vielfach für den
nächsten haushalt vor
kleiner tipp bist du nicht recht war
meine damen und herren sobald sich der
fallschirm öffnet sich hier drauf und
dann muss man also max es geht los
eine hatte oder ob ich lande auch schon
bescheuert wieder hier
ich hoffe dass ich überhaupt gegen
welche waffen hier finde ich finde keine
waffen kuba wo ich raus gesprungen bin
aber das ist ja deswegen weil ich muss
mich so richtig lang machen über super
hier auch feuchte ich mich in sachen 124
sekunden können wir nicht mal irgendwo
ein paar waffen herumliegen leute häuser
also geil
maxivista starke bafana das krieg ich
das hinkriege das wäre so cool also
leute ganz im ernst
dieses spiel hat mir hätte die gesucht
gefahr
max ist ja auch okay willst du auch
irgendwie noch mal irgendwann mit
johannes hat ist ja noch ein richtiges
auto ist kaputt
passiert so cool ist ne du kannst wenn
du fliegst irgendwie in der luft wird
und von dem
doch meine kappe der trend machen dass
du kleiner
wie hätte ich denn ab heute den
verfahren dass wir das jetzt in diesen
wir bisher leider verschwindet
haltestelle ist das mag schreibt wir so
hell wie hast du noch ideen fehlt welche
aufgaben und das treibt der städte der
papst habe schon jetzt richtig an
reinfall schon was ich sagen werde ich
leute wenn ich diese runde kein kill
mache dann werde ich zwei changes nehmen
ich muss mir selbst ein fachanwalt
schaffen wenn du schaffst teilen mit dem
dingen zu überfahren
dann nämlich den challenge lasst doch
die 10 grad damit ist im ganzen haus
jetzt warten wir nur so kann daten sind
wirst du meine wird selbst getan ich
habe mit ihm fast tot und das sieht aus
wie eine waffe schon kurze nachricht
die sieht richtig gut aus das waren laut
der verfahren geben
das nicht
jana funktionieren sich anderen parteien
sieht so ein kellner aber immerhin ein
kind macht sonst hätte ich auch zwei
nehmen müssen stimmen aber jetzt nehmen
wir hier jetzt noch hohe die schüssel
hashtag ein special ist was wir da tun
dass der andere besser in cod ist okay
dass auch hätten das nicht besser in
call of duty den ersten kiel gemacht und
ich bin besser luft auf cnet umsteigen
und teils und seiner snap das soll dass
ich besser bin als er in call of duty
ihr seht es sogar dass sie genau portal
twitter dass der andere deshalb würde
ist also nicht nur sie schreiben dass
der andere westernserie also leute hier
das video bitten wir sie das foto hier
ist jetzt an der story wachsen kann ja
nochmal einblenden und jahre alte wir
haben in vier games zusammen zwei kills
geschafft ligabetrieb bisschen besser
noch jetzt nach dem video ist es losgeht
hat einen kommentar mit den hashtags
specialist hashtags rock und hashtag
teamchefs und ich bin topfit warum ihr
dritten teil von
ich hoffe das video durch spaß gemacht
schaut mal vorbei sein name ist luca